supongamos que tenemos un triángulo aquí
voy a pintar el triángulo en color
naranja y que sabemos que las longitudes
de sus lados son a b y c y que a partir
de esta información queremos determinar
el área del triángulo tenemos una
fórmula muy clásica para encontrar esto
el área que nos dice que el área el área
es igual a un medio del producto de la
base de la base con la altura altura
altura sin embargo no podemos utilizar
esta fórmula en este problema de aquí
porque aunque sepamos por ejemplo que se
es la base que esto de acá me dice pues
no tenemos información acerca de la
altura la altura es una recta pues rara
diferente a estas que pasa por el medio
del triángulo y que baja
perpendicularmente que si le ponemos que
mide h pues no sabemos todavía cómo
relacionarla con ave y se salen
ahora si viste el vídeo anterior
seguramente me vas a decir bueno pues
podemos utilizar la fórmula de heron si
aquí podemos utilizarla pero justo a la
idea de este vídeo y de el siguiente es
demostrar esa fórmula es decir lo que
queremos hacer es ver por qué siempre es
cierta vale y para hacer eso lo que
vamos a hacer es utilizar el teorema de
pitágoras un par de veces y luego vamos
a hacer algunas simplificaciones
algebraicas vamos a empezar con esto
primero déjame introducir una variable
auxiliar que le vamos a poner x que va a
ser la distancia de este vértice al pie
de la altura este de aquí este cachito
de aquí vamos a poner que mide x eso es
un truco muy común en geometría sale
y entonces si este cachito de acá me de
x lo que va de este pies de altura a
este vértice de acá es cm x para que
entre los dos
súmense que es la longitud de este lado
es menos x y con estas longitudes ahora
sí déjame aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras a este triángulo rectángulo de
acá y a este de acá déjame ponerlo por
acá para ver qué queda nos quedaría que
x al cuadrado más h al cuadrado es igual
a al cuadrado eso es este triángulo y
que se menos x al cuadrado
c - x elevado al cuadrado más h al
cuadrado al cuadrado es igual a b al
cuadrado eso es este triángulo
rectángulo de acá bueno observa que aquí
tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones en dos
variables y que consta de dos ecuaciones
las variables son x y h y entonces con
un poco de suerte podemos encontrar el
valor de h en términos de a b y c y
después sustituirlo aquí arriba para ver
que nos queda y avanzar hacia la fórmula
de heron vamos a hacer eso déjame
empezar despejando h de aquí nos queda
que h al cuadrado es igual a al cuadrado
menos x al cuadrado y ahora este valor
de h cuadrada lo voy a sus a sustituir
aquí abajo es decir nos quedaría hace
menos x al cuadrado que lo voy a
desarrollar de una vez es un binomio al
cuadrado nos quedaría se cuadrada menos
dos veces c x + x al cuadrado más h al
cuadrado que es esta expresión que
encontramos
a cuadrada menos x al cuadrado al
cuadrado es igual a b al cuadrado es
igual al cuadrado y aquí ya no tenemos h
entonces podemos despejar x vamos a
hacer esto pero primero déjame cancelar
x al cuadrado con menos x al cuadrado y
ahora lo que tendríamos que hacer es
pasar lo que tiene x de un lado y lo que
no de otro déjame sumar 2 veces x de
ambos lados de la igualdad más 2 veces 2
veces x y restar b cuadrado menos b
cuadrada menos b cuadrado
entonces b cuadrado se cancela con menos
b cuadrada menos 12 x con 12 x y
obtenemos lo siguiente obtenemos que se
cuadrada más a cuadrada se cuadrada más
a cuadrada menos b cuadrada menos b
cuadrada es igual a dos veces c x y para
despejar x simplemente dividimos entre 2
se nos queda que x
x es igual a c cuadrada más a cuadrada
cuadrada menos b cuadrada dividido entre
dos veces c este de aquí es el valor de
x este valor de x lo podemos sustituir
aquí arriba para determinar el valor del
h vamos a hacer eso nos quedaría que h
cuadrada h cuadrada es igual a cuadrada
menos x al cuadrado déjame abrir un
paréntesis para escribir esta expresión
x al cuadrado y sx es se cuadrada más a
cuadrada menos menos b cuadrada entre 2
c pero esto está h cuadrada y nosotros
queremos h así que voy a sacar una raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados nos quedaría que
h es igual a la raíz cuadrada de a
cuadrada a cuadrada menos aquí va este
paréntesis grande
grande elevado al cuadrado dividido
entre el denominador es 12 y arriba nos
queda se cuadrada más cuadrada menos b
cuadrada muy bien y con eso obtenemos el
valor de h ahora sí podemos regresar a
determinar el área déjame ponerle aquí
abajo área otra vez área
área y eso nos queda igual a un medio de
c x este valor de h que encontramos lo
voy a poner acá no quedaría un medio de
c por la raíz cuadrada de a cuadrada
menos abro paréntesis aquí va a quedar
elevado al cuadrado se cuadrada más a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada y eso dividido
entre dos veces c y esto está súper
padre ya tenemos una expresión del área
en términos de los lados de a b y c esto
ya es un muy buen paso para avanzar
hacia asia hacia la fórmula de heron de
hecho esto básicamente es la fórmula
deron es una expresión equivalente a lo
mejor no parece la fórmula de heron pero
después de algunas manipulaciones
algebraicas vamos a obtener la fórmula
que vimos en el vídeo pasado sale ahora
una cosa buena es que esto ya es una
fórmula que depende únicamente de a b y
c
entonces si quisieras si te dieran ganas
de aprender de esta fórmula que se ve un
poco más fea
ya ya podrías encontrar el área de un
triángulo conociendo sus lados vale
bueno vamos a dejar la simplificación
algebraica para el próximo vídeo pero lo
que vamos a hacer ahorita es ver que
vamos avanzando bien comprobando que
obtenemos la misma área para el
triángulo del vídeo pasado utilizando
esta fórmula de acá vale bueno entonces
déjame poner el triángulo del vídeo
pasado era un triángulo más o menos así
y algo de este estilo donde dijimos que
los lados medían 9 11 y 16 y 16 sale y
según la fórmula de heron que utilizamos
en el vídeo pasado nos quedaba que el
área era 18 raíz de 7 lo que vamos a
hacer es ver si esta misma fórmula que
obtuvimos a partir de los teoremas de
pitágoras y esta fórmula de área nos da
la misma área vale entonces déjame hacer
las sustituciones en esta fórmula de acá
lo voy a poner aquí abajo en color
amarillo en el color amarillo el área es
igual a un medio de c 616 entonces es
igual a 8 x la raíz cuadrada voy a
necesitar aquí espacio de a al cuadrado
o sea 81 9 al cuadrado es 81 - aquí va
un paréntesis grande elevado al cuadrado
menos sé cuadrada se cuadra de 16 al
cuadrado osea 256
más cuadrada o sea más 81 81
-11 al cuadrado o sea 121 dividido entre
dos veces c o sea entre 2 por 16 entre
32 bueno déjame simplificar un poco esto
nos quedaría que el área es igual a 8
veces la raíz cuadrada de 81 - y vamos a
ver que queda dentro del paréntesis
dentro del paréntesis queda 256 más 81
menos 121 81 menos 121 es menos 40
entonces nos queda 216 216 dividido
entre 32 y eso tenemos que elevarlo al
cuadrado si te das cuenta aquí la
aritmética las cuentitas van a salir muy
difíciles pero ya le avanzamos bastante
déjame meter esto en la calculadora para
ver si obtenemos lo mismo que aquí
arriba entonces voy a sacar la
calculadora déjame ponerla por aquí
y vamos a ver primero cuánto es 18 raíz
de 7 18 por la raíz cuadrada raíz
cuadrada de 7
eso es 47 puntos 62 35 ok
ese es el área que obtuvimos en el vídeo
pasado ahora vamos a ver cuál es el área
que obtuvimos utilizando esta fórmula a
la cual ya le avanzamos nos quedaría 88
multiplicado por la raíz cuadrada de 81
- y aquí hay que abrir parientes
paréntesis 216 dividido entre 32 cierro
paréntesis eso lo elevó al cuadrado y
cierro la raíz cuadrada y nos queda lo
mismo 47.62 35 entonces esta es una muy
buena indicación y de hecho está padre
que haya salido lo mismo porque porque a
lo mejor cometió un error pero bueno ya
vimos que no lo hice entonces esto en
efecto nos dice que vamos por buen
camino para demostrar la fórmula la
fórmula de heron vamos a ver cómo a
partir de algunas cuentas simplificamos
esta expresión a la del vídeo pasado que
es más fácil de memorizar y está más
bonita vale nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo